we welcome anthony pompliano founder and
partner of pomp investment pomp good to
see you
um sporting the hoodie as usual so
when i hear something goes from
contrarian to consensus
i sort of think
is that a good thing
really yeah it's a great question um i
think there's a couple of things to know
here so first of all is adoption happens
in cohorts of bitcoin and it's happened
in reverse so first we've got the
individuals all across the internet you
know millions and millions of people uh
student anonymously adopting this
digital store value we then started to
see this year organization so we saw a
kind of end of last year ended this year
uh corporations both public and private
also financial institutions started to
actually allocate to the asset class and
then we got one nation state that
started uh it's kind of that third
cohort so individuals your organizations
the nation states i think the key piece
is that uh it had already gone from kind
of a contrarian to consensus idea in
individuals but 2021 was really the year
that we saw the mainstream wall street
organizations and also corporations say
hey look i gotta have a strategy the
strategy maybe i'm gonna sit it out but
i at least have to have the conversation
to go ahead and figure out should i buy
some should i not should i build a
company in this space should i build a
product what am i going to do in terms
of the bitcoin strategy and i think that
that ultimately is a tailwind for the
industry i'm assuming you're a bull in
terms of bitcoin price action 2022
anthony so i'm wondering a
where do you think bitcoin is headed in
2022 and what you think the biggest
catalyst is going to be of the ones that
you named i mean it's going to be more
corporate adoption is it going to be
more nation states adopting bitcoin as
currency
yeah so i think there's a couple things
so back in 2019 i basically said look i
think bitcoin's going to hit 100k by the
end of 2021 and really the thesis was
simple it was look we're going to get
the having uh in 2020 18 months later
usually we see some sort of blow off top
we didn't really get the blow off top so
for two and a half years you know called
for a 10x we got about a 7x um which i
think was a little surprising one of the
things i'm watching though is that 18
month time frame may be off we may
actually be seeing longer bull markets
now rather than kind of those 18 months
one that we've seen before time will
tell hindsight will be kind of 20 20 on
that i think that's one thing to watch
the other thing that i'm watching right
now i don't think we have enough data
yet but over the last couple of weeks
i've seen a couple of analysts talking
about this idea that bitcoin's price is
actually tracking uh correlated to the
10-year treasury yield and so now you
would think that most risk assets as the
interest rates get
raised we should see risk assets
actually sell off right if you go all
the way back to the 99.com bubble a lot
of people would point to interest rates
being a key factor for kind of popping
that bubble but if bitcoins can actually
trade alongside it again we do need more
data but if that is true in some crazy
way raising interest rates could be
bullish for bitcoin now i don't haven't
had enough time to see enough data nor
think through enough of like why that
may be but i do think that's something
that investors probably aren't thinking
about right now and it would go counter
to the narrative that we've seen in
terms of some of the macro thoughts
again let's wait to see what data
happens here but if the fed does raise
interest rates and we continue to see
bitcoins uh kind of price track that uh
treasury yield that'd be very
interesting and i think a surprise to
many people in the market